this week
planting trees to save the planet from
wildfires to illegal logging
the world's forests have been decimated
in the 21st century
why reforestation is so important if
it's done correctly monoculture
plantations don't have any biodiversity
and have very low biodiversity
and they don't capture as much carbon as
natural first
carbon offsets are a win-win on paper
companies get to net zero and countries
protect their forests
but our investigation finds that not all
projects are what they seem
as we begin to look at the carbon offset
projects themselves
what we found is that the environmental
benefits claimed by these companies are
not actually
what they seem to be plus crimes against
the planet newly defined ecocide could
soon be a crime
tried by the international criminal
court putting guilty ceos
on the same level as war criminals
damage to nature
is simply not taken seriously enough and
we're seeing on an ever more apocalyptic
scale what the result of that is
i'm kaylee lyons in new york and this is
bloomberg green
[Music]
we've lost 10 percent of the world's
forest in the last 20 years
and the pace of destruction is not
slowing down according to brazil's space
research agency
last month was the worst on record for
amazon rainforest destruction
with 1180 square kilometers lost
and after major forest fires in the
amazon california and australia
global attention has now turned to
reforestation
but it's not as simple as just planting
trees
bloomberg's oxshotrati explains three
lessons about trees
and climate
trees aren't the simple climate solution
you think they are
in trees we already have a vacuum
cleaner for the sky
these majestic species of all shapes and
sizes
soak up carbon dioxide and store it away
for decades or even centuries
but we are losing trees at an alarming
rate
we've lost 10 percent of the world's
forest in the last 20 years
that works out to losing a football
field worth of freeze
every second if we want trees to be a
climate solution to their full potential
we don't just need to stop deforestation
but reverse the trend
by growing forest cover sounds simple
right
but years of trial and error have shown
that it is not
experts who have studied tree planting
programs say there are three key lessons
one grow a forest not a plantation
don't just plant one or two fast-growing
species of trees
they may soak up carbon in the short
term but the lack of diversity
makes them vulnerable to pests droughts
floods and forest fires
two be careful in choosing where you
plant the trees
trees may soak up carbon but they also
play a significant role in absorbing
or reflecting sunlight forest closer to
the poles
may actually increase the warming of the
planet scientists have found that
growing trees closer to the equator
is much more beneficial three beware
the risk of green colonialism if the
world needs to plant a trillion more
trees
then we will need land the size of china
to grow them
that kind of expansion will pit human
needs against global climate goals
tree planting should not conflict with
the needs of local people
instead working with local populations
helps ensure that the trees remain
sucking up carbon for much longer
done right trees will be a key climate
solution
but trees aren't a get out of jail card
they won't be effective unless the world
cuts
emissions first this is net zero
i'm akshatrati for more stories like
this you can find us on your favorite
platforms
joining us now to talk more about this
is merrill vandermark she is from the
rainforest action network an
organization that was founded in 1985
with an aim to end deforestation and
uphold indigenous human
rights merrill it's great to speak with
you let's talk about the problem
first when we talk about forest
destruction at what scale
are we talking at a huge scale
just last year we lost over four million
hectares of
tropical forests around the world and
this tends to be increasing
so yeah there's a huge deforestation
issue we're losing our
our main forest which holds huge
biodiversity that hold most of the
biodiversity that we have
on earth on tours to earth and that are
key
to to fight climate change you mentioned
the biodiversity
impact what else what else do we need to
worry about when we think about losing
our force what other issues result from
it
so fars are really important carbon sink
as our peatlands that are often
together found in the same places as far
as so that's a huge
important issue that we shouldn't lose
these carbon chains and in fact we
should
expand them so that we can capture more
carbon and mitigate the effects of
climate change
as i said they are the major um they
hold most of the biodiversity to rest of
biodiversity
on earth so that's very important for
keeping biodiversity
and increasing our resilience for the
impacts of climate change
um forests are also home to millions of
people that directly depend
for their livelihoods on the forest so
protecting these forests is also
a way to protect indigenous people
traditional communities that really
use the forest as their for the
subsistence obviously carbon offsets are
getting a lot of attention as the world
looks more toward
net zero is there anything about the
carbon offset market that worries you do
you
get concerned that money may be going to
the wrong places
yes absolutely first because carbon
offsets
they're not the same as decarbonization
right an offset is just a way to con
it can be just a way to continue
polluting while
someone else does the work of either
protecting a forest or reducing
emissions
and we need to reduce the emissions of
the world
to such a degree that we really need all
the companies and banks
to reduce their own emissions before
they start thinking about about offsets
and then there's a huge issue with
respecting indigenous people's rights
and
local communities rights because some of
these offsets are
being imposed top down on local
communities and they're act
they're having huge impacts on their
livelihoods on the rights of defenders
and they're not doing the what they what
they're made to do which is to protect
the climate and the forests
thank you so much to merrill vandermark
from the rainforest action network
coming up these trees are not what they
seem
a bloomberg investigation uncovers the
murky world behind carbon offsets
and why the route to net zero might be
harder than just planting forests
this is bloomberg green
[Music]
this is bloomberg green i'm jennifer's
avasanja in new york with your green
brief we at reliance have
adopted this wholeheartedly asia's
richest man says
businesses need to go green to survive
mukesh ambani told the qatar economic
forum
that he plans to transform all of the
units in his conglomerate
reliance industries as he aims for net
zero by 2035.
his firm got 60 percent of its revenue
from energy in the last year
australia is rejecting a warning about
the great barrier reef the government is
opposing an effort by unesco to
categorize the world's biggest coral
ecosystem
as endangered australia says the world's
reefs are threatened by climate change
but rejects singling out one
and could aluminum be both a cause of
climate change and its cure
that's what goldman sachs believes it
says demand is expected to surge with
the metal being
a key ingredient in green tech like evs
and solar power
but it's also very carbon intensive with
the bank estimating it generates two
percent
of all global emissions and that's your
green brief
kaley
thanks jen net zero is now the holy
grail of hundreds of companies and
governments around the world
and planting trees may hold the key to
progress
consumers can now fly buy and eat safe
in the knowledge that the businesses
their money goes to
are slashing emissions in the name of
climate or are they
for many reducing emissions is certainly
a part of the solution
but carbon offsets may be an equal or
even bigger part
billions now flow into projects trying
to balance the carbon books
but the big question is do they work
it's very important given the nature of
the climate crisis
right now for the general public to have
an understanding of what
progress is or is not actually happening
and i think many readers right now
they'll see these hundreds and hundreds
of companies making these
big bold climate uh claims
and they would be forgiven to think that
you know we're well on our way to
meeting the emission reduction
trajectory we need to be on and the
reality of the matter is we're just
not on that trajectory and it and a key
reason for this sort of disconnect is
the use of
offsets that aren't doing what they
claim to be doing
my name is ben elgin i wrote the story
about how the billion dollar market for
carbon offsets is setting back the fight
against climate change
my name is mark trexler i've worked in
climate change for the last
30 years i was actually hired by the
world resources institute in washington
to work on the first
carbon offset project in 1988.
in terms of defining a carbon offset the
one of the beauties
so to speak of greenhouse gases sort of
the silver lining of greenhouse gases
when you put up a molecule of co2 into
the atmosphere
it can be anywhere in the planet in
seven days
and therefore you know if there's an
option to reduce
emissions on the other side of the
planet and you can do that very
cheaply as compared to doing it in your
factory for example
then why not pay that person that
factory on the other side of the planet
to reduce their emissions
then you are in a sense offsetting
your emissions and the atmosphere
doesn't really see your
emissions anymore we've seen
a huge surge in companies making big
proclamations about how they're going
carbon neutral or zeroing out
all of their carbon emissions we began
looking at these corporate claims of
dramatically reduced emissions
and we noticed so many of these
companies
were using carbon offsets to uh to to
achieve these aims
and as we began to look at the carbon
offset projects themselves
what we found is that the environmental
benefits claimed by these
companies are not actually what they
what they seem to be
and as we sort of saw and spotted a
number of these very aggressive carbon
offset projects which appeared to be
generating
inflated credits or bogus credits we saw
a number of them were associated with
the nature conservancy
[Music]
and this surprised us the nature
conservancy is the world's biggest
environmental group
they have about a billion dollars a year
in revenues
and they've been around for seven
decades uh they've preserved about 125
million
acres of land uh and they've done so
many good works over the years and
they've been very strong in terms of
working with
20 corporate partners to visit disney
world this year
[Music]
if you look at for instance disney
that's a sprawling company with
theme parks and cruise lines that burn
up
diesel fuel they have office buildings
and television studios that consume
electricity
uh so these companies are trying to make
major major reductions in their carbon
footprints but it's very difficult to
change these fundamental ways their
businesses
operate so disney has been a big buyer
of carbon offsets
that are orchestrated by the nature
conservancy
one of the projects that they buy from
is called pennsylvania ridges
and that's a plot of land most of the
land is actually about a three-hour
drive outside of philadelphia
interestingly this land 3000 of these
acres
was actually acquired by the nature
conservancy in the late 1990s
this land was imminently threatened
there was a pending logging contract on
this land
so they they do what they they've done
so well for all of these years which is
they go out
they raise money from local
philanthropists and they go buy this
land to protect it from developers and
loggers
and at the time according to an archived
version of the nature conservancy's
website
they when they were proudly announcing
this deal they said
these threats have been abated because
of this acquisition by the nature
conservancy
so it's really interesting now fast
forward two decades to earlier this year
when they put forward this carbon
project and if you look through it
this land is a key part of that carbon
project
and what they're now saying is this land
is now once again
imminently threatened uh 72 percent of
the trees
are going to be cut within five years
now this is just astounding because this
land is owned by the nature conservancy
they do not clear cut land that they've
bought
through philanthropic donations
so this scenario that they've put
forward to get carbon revenues
is not really plausible and what that
means is when you have disney coming in
and buying these credits when it
eventually
lowers its carbon footprint because of
these credits
well that won't be a credible or
truthful claim by disney
so the nature conservancy defends
vigorously these deals
and and they and others will say look
our projects are just following the
rules that these registries set up
um so some would also put some of the
blame on the registries themselves
because they're setting up the rules
which
allow these vapid projects to get up and
sold
most of these nature conservancy deals
are
set up and sold on this exchange it's
called the american carbon registry
one of the the challenges with with
designing carbon offset systems
is that there are normally two people at
the table
you have buyers and you have sellers and
to some extent you have policy makers
but
but you know the buyers and the sellers
are really the ones with the expertise
with the with the incentive to really
participate hard
make a lot of things happen uh and the
the challenge there is
is that both of them sort of want the
same thing or they're both happy with
the same thing they're happy with low
cost
offsets and a lot of them
ultimately what needs to be what needs
to happen is systemic
change you know we're sort of nibbling
around the edges with some of these
different things
we need to change how we produce energy
we need to change how we transport
ourselves we need to change
what and how we eat you know we we need
systemic change associated with
transitioning to a low carbon
economy a lot of what we're doing today
is not promoting systemic change it's
sort of trying to stick your
your thumb in the dike to preserve the
current system
and and at the end of the day that can't
really
[Music]
work
[Music]
coming up environmental destruction
harms us all
but could the people behind it soon be
tried alongside war criminals
a panel lawyers thinks they should and
is drafting a new definition
of ecocide to do so this
is bloomberg green
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
from bloomberg's headquarters in new
york i'm kaylee lynes and this
is bloomberg green well global
environmental rules are patchy at best
which means holding multinational actors
to account can be tricky
even when companies are taken to court
fines are often absorbed and business
continues
but now a panel of lawyers is drafting a
definition of ecocide
to submit to the international criminal
court in hopes that raising
environmental destruction to the level
of genocide
will reign in some of humanity's worst
excesses
this decade is going to be decisive in
how we
approach dealing with the climate crisis
dealing with the ecological crisis
um and dealing with ecocide is a bit
like going to the root cause so climate
change if you like
it is a symptom and you know mass damage
and destruction of ecosystems is
actually one of the root causes
when bp spilled 210 million gallons of
oil into the mexican gulf in 2010
it wasn't just seabirds and dolphins
that were the victims
ten years on the natural resources
defense council estimates that the
overall cost to fisheries in the gulf
was 8.7 billion dollars
with a loss of more than 20 000 jobs
white house energy advisor carol browner
called it the worst environmental
disaster the us
have faced bp was hit with a record fine
of 20 billion dollars
but deep water drilling continues to
this day
a growing number of people think that
the courts did not go
far enough damage to nature is simply
not taken seriously enough
as we can see our economic system is set
up around maximizing profit
and doing so within certain ground rules
like you know you don't kill anybody
um but those ground rules don't include
serious damage to nature and we're
seeing on an ever more apocalyptic scale
what the result of that is
so what if there was a different way
what if
instead of shrugging off fines as
exceptional expenses
decision makers could be tried alongside
war criminals
and those who committed genocide
it may sound extreme but that's what
supporters of eco side law
want the international criminal law is
really about
human survival and human dignity it's
very much
focused on human race and we have
genocide elimination of a human group
or crimes against humanity what could be
more of an international crime
in other words a crime that no matter
where it occurs on the planet affects
all of us
than destruction of our very environment
kate mcintosh and jojo meta are part of
a panel of lawyers
currently drafting legislation to be
presented to the international
criminal court the best chance yet for
ecocide to be made into law
it's a long road to ratification but
supporters include french president
emmanuel macron greta toomberg and even
pope francis so what we're wanting
corporations to see this as is a
guardrail but also as a challenge
you know it's like you know what we want
we want those ceos to be saying
you know i can see this coming down the
line and it's very sensible it's
ultimately it's almost like a health and
safety regulation for the planet
you know how do we comply with that new
health and safety regulation we we want
to be ahead of that curve
because we want to be placed in a way to
take things forward in a way that is
sustainable and that is actually helping
the planet to thrive
rather than destroying it as we go
the lawyers pursuing ecocide believe it
must
be on a level with genocide or crimes
against humanity
it might be hard to imagine ceos in the
dock alongside
dictators and despots but it's hope the
threat of prosecution will be enough to
change behaviour
we're not talking about genocidal
maniacs
or warlords that are trying to win
territory we're talking about
basically reasonable people who are
going about their business
and i can't imagine that those people
would feel comfortable
about being potentially prosecuted as an
international criminal
in the same way that they might feel
quite comfortable about
dealing with fines that would result
from civil suits brought against them
despite optimism and widespread public
support
ecocide laws are at least a few years
off
even if the icc accepts the new
definition of ecocide
one of its 123 member states will still
need to propose it
and the rest will have their turns
squabbling over the details
only then could enforcement begin
lawyers estimate that could take up to
four years
but that might be just what businesses
need to get their houses
in order of course there will need to be
a transition period i'm not gonna
you know make any bones about that you
know if we brought this law in tomorrow
it would be chaos
it's not about an instant change that's
gonna somehow you know dump everybody
somewhere that they're completely
unfamiliar and don't know what to do
this is about looking at something
that's coming down the line because
something like this will have to come
sooner or later
we're looking at something coming down
the line within the next few years
that inspires compliance pathways
transition policies
you know all of these kind of things
that will need you know adjustments that
will need to be made
but will need to be made with a very
different future in mind a future that
we all know we have to approach
the power of ecocide law lies in
criminalizing the destruction of nature
on an individual level next time a
company causes an oil spill its decision
makers
could be facing jail time and that
personal accountability
is what its supporters say will drive
the change
effectively what you're looking at is an
individual
being held to account because they're in
a decision-making position
within that project and that's precisely
again where the power comes in
because it's easy to hide behind the
corporate veil and have your company
fine for something you made a decision
for but once
that sort of protection is removed
you're going to think a lot harder it's
a serious concentration for the mind
that's it for this week's edition but
keep the conversation going
follow us on twitter at climate i'm
kaylee lyons in new york
and this is bloomberg green